die jetzige situation ist neu für alle
von uns allen sind besonnenheit und
solidarität gefragt wir wollen dabei
helfen mit unserer informationen und
antworten uns alltag verändert sich lieb
gewonnene gewohnheiten müssen wir lassen
uns um organisieren auch so manches
verzichten
dort ferber über fragen die plötzlich
unseren alltag bestimmen die senioren
computer ag ist an diesem morgen gut
besucht
sie treffen sich einmal wöchentlich sie
tauschen sich aus für alle hier ein
wichtiger termin an dem erhalten sie
auch in corona zeiten fest dem virus
begegnen sie mit einer gewissen
gelassenheit des alters in der
zahnarztpraxis merken sie dagegen einen
unterschied die virus angst hat auch die
patienten im griff und da verschieben
selbst jüngere gerne mal die
zahnreinigung wir sehen schon dass
patienten ab sagen dass patienten
verunsichert sind und auch nachfragen
und wir fragen auch unsere patienten
weswegen sie die sorgen haben und
stellen natürlich auch fragen ob sie aus
risikogebieten kommen oder ob
krankheitssymptome vorlägen patient
frank der häuser ist zum termin gekommen
nur die praxistür mochte er lieber nicht
mit der hand öffnen
denn den ärmel genommen habe und dann
die klinke gedrückt habe also man ist er
halt bisschen sensibilisiert im yoga
studio werden die matten sorgfältig
desinfiziert
hier kommen weniger leute als
normalerweise der kurs einer firmen
belegschaft fällt ganz aus und ansonsten
ist alles ein bisschen anders
tatsächlich gucke ich dass ich die leute
nicht mehr so viel an fast weil ich
denke nur der eine oder andere hat er
vielleicht dann doch noch mehr sorge
sonst was sich die leute auch schon mal
ein bisschen mehr an und die leute
rücken von selber ein bisschen mehr
auseinander dass merkel schon sobald
jemand hustet genug platz ist jedenfalls
derzeit in einigen kursen ist gerade
noch eine handvoll teilnehmer ich
praktizierten mehr zu hause als in
studios und ich meine im moment studios
in denen ich weiß dass freundliche junge
frauen oder viele frauen sehr meistens
frauen auch erkältet zum yoga gehen
etwas entspannung in angespannten zeiten
yoga soll ja auch das immunsystem
stärken
entspannung bietet auch ein
feierabendbier mit freunden in der
nachbarschaft kneipe und die gäste hier
sind tatsächlich sehr gelassen
ich war so ein bisschen auf somit
händewaschen waren so ein bisschen
abstand halten auch im öffentlichen
verkehr
das mittelbare jetzt ich versuche so den
ball flach zu halten also ich mache mir
die hände immer weil ich bin auch selber
kopf und es muss halt mehr darauf achten
noch mehrere waren als vorher
und ja gut ich merkte dass die gäste
ausbleiben und so aber ich große meinem
alltag was ändern main events kommt dann
kommt sich irgendwie stärken für den
alltag
auch darum geht es wohl in diesen nicht
alltäglichen zeiten
wir haben uns umgehört dem süden im
osten und im norden des landes wir
wollten von ihnen wissen was sie
beschäftigt was sie nicht verstehen
welche fragen offen sind
antworten gibt es unter anderem von
sarah tacke leiterin der zdf rechts
redaktion hallo sagen dass du uns bei
dieser aufgabe helfen wirst hier kommen
auch schon seine ersten drei fragen uns
beschäftigt sehr die frage ob anfang mai
ist wieder möglich ist mit dem fahrrad
von münchen nach venedig zu fahren das
heißt wir würden ja nach norditalien
fahren darüber hinaus interessiert uns
natürlich auch alles ist gebucht die
fahrkarten sind gekauft bekommen wir das
erstattet ich frage mich ob ein
arbeitsausfall wer wer übernimmt die
kosten aus der perspektive von
angestellten der freigestellt wird und
seinem arbeitgeber greift das irgend
einer arbeitsunfähigkeit regelung oder
oder gibt es kurzfristig und kulant das
kurzarbeitergeld oder ja wo kriegt er
angestellter sein geld hier und ich habe
mir einen flug nach amerika gebucht und
kann den wegen des einreiseverbots jetzt
nicht wahrnehmen
meine fluggesellschaft sagt mir ich soll
zu einem anderen zeitpunkt einreisen
aber das kann ich nicht kann ich da
rechtlich was gegen tun
wir sortieren ganz kurz die fragen
vielleicht sarah zuerst zu dem punkt
reisen was sind deine antworten genau
die frage flug ist ganz einfach zu
beantworten wenn der flug storniert wird
abgesagt wird dann habe ich darf den
anspruch den ticketpreis sicher bekommen
und zwar egal ob wegen corona oder wieso
auch immer ich bekomme den ticketpreis
auf jeden fall erstattet und ich muss
auch nicht auf einen anderen termin
ausreichen weil ich habe den flug zu dem
zeitpunkt gebucht ist genau wie bei
einem konzert
wenn ein konzert verschoben werden soll
muss ich auch nicht darauf eingehen weil
ich hab ein konzertticket für diesen
konzerttag wie ist es mit der bahnfahrt
nach norditalien norditalien ist er
besonders betroffen
der kunststoff an also aktuell ist es so
dass die bahn allein aus kulanz sagt man
kann bei reisen nach norditalien
stornieren aber das ist im moment jetzt
die frage ist wie wird sich das weiter
entwickeln welche situation haben wir
mai in norditalien und das natürlich
ganz schwer abzusehen
und da an der frage hier noch ran was
ist mit den sonstigen buchungen wenn man
jetzt aktuell eine pauschalreise nach
norditalien gebucht hat dann wird die
auch komplett erstattet weil man kann
jetzt nicht mit dem fahrrad durch
norditalien fahren wie das im mai im
juni im august aussieht muss man dann
sehen
und wenn man einzelne bausteine gebucht
hat beispielsweise ein hotel in
norditalien ist die frage ist das immer
noch unter quarantäne
trägt man es erstattet wenn nicht muss
man vielleicht auch reisen thema
arbeitsausfall die frage war ganz
konkret woher kriege ich das geld her
also wenn mein betrieb schließt
vorsorglich aus angst vor corona zum
beispiel dann muss ich ganz normal
weiter bezahlt werden und dahin ja auch
noch mit dran was ist eigentlich für den
unternehmer selber der muss seine
arbeitnehmer weiter zahlen und am ende
ist es sein wirtschaftliches risiko
deshalb wird hier gerade aktuell ganz
viel getan kredite kurzarbeitergeld um
dafür zu sorgen dass diese corona krise
uns wirtschaftlich nicht ruiniert und
viele unternehmen in die knie zieht eine
frage noch eine nachfrage von mir zum
thema geschlossene schulen das bewegte
heute wirklich ganz ganz viele menschen
die schule geschlossen ich habe ein
betreuungsproblem kann ich mich krank
werden jetzt betrifft ganz ganz viele
eltern schulen und kitas grundsätzlich
gilt wenn der schule oder kita
geschlossen wird muss ich mich als
elternteil umsatz betreuung kümmern
aber man hat eine gewisse übergangszeit
bis zu fünf tage sind möglich da kann
man sagt dass es unvorhergesehen und
kann dann ersatzbetreuung organisieren
hier geht es aber natürlich um drei vier
wochen die man überbrücken muss und da
hilft es ehrlich gesagt nur mit seinem
arbeitgeber ins gespräch gehen weil man
auf nichts in anspruch hatte aber man
kann natürlich fragen ist der tumor ist
möglich oder unbezahlter urlaub ganz
kurz
eine kurze antwort bitte unbezahlter
urlaub ist eine lösung habe ich dann
recht darauf eigentlich man hat auch
nicht zum recht deswegen wirklich der
rat mit seinem arbeitgeber ins gespräch
gehen und schauen was ist möglich was
ist gut für beide seiten sagen vielen
dank bisher weitere fragen kommen dann
später noch nie ist deutschland auf die
krise vorbereitet eine dieser fragen die
wirklich alle umtreibt und auch uns oft
gestellt wird und wurde fakten zu
unserem gesundheitssystem von
christopher emmerling in deutschland
gibt es etwa 497.000 krankenhausbetten
davon sind ca 28.000 intensivbetten
intensivbetten heißt hier können
patienten behandelt werden die besonders
betreuungsintensiven sind in der regel
sind diese betten auch mit einem
beatmungsgerät ausgestattet und
immungeschwächte reagieren häufig mit
einer störung der lungenfunktion das
heißt der körper nimmt nicht mehr
genügend sauerstoff auf als
unterstützung werden diese patienten an
beatmungsgeräte gehängt und das können
sie natürlich nicht auf der
normalstation leisten
etwa 80 prozent der intensivbetten sind
im schnitt über das jahr belegt in
hochzeiten einer grippewelle zum
beispiel gerne auch mehr
ein pfleger ist hier maximal für 25
patienten zuständig doch speziell beim
personal könnte es zu problemen kommen
17.000 pflegestellen sind in deutschland
sowieso chronisch unbesetzt zu weiteren
engpässen kann es aber schnell kommen
wenn sich ärzte oder pflegekräfte selbst
infizieren
wir machen es so dass nur feste
pflegekräfte dann auch in dieses zimmer
rein gehen um nicht alle schwestern von
der intensivstation mit diesen patienten
in kontakt zu bringen
noch haben die experten in deutschland
wenig erfahrungswerte mit dem virus
chinesische fallzahlen gehen im
durchschnitt von etwa zehn tagen
krankenhausaufenthalt pro corona patient
aus da schwere fälle einen
krankheitsverlauf von bis zu sechs
wochen haben können geht das robert koch
institut jedoch tatsächlich von einer
längeren aufenthaltsdauer aus bei uns im
studio begrüße ich jetzt sabine bätzing
lichtenthäler gesundheitsministerin in
rheinland-pfalz guten abend schön dass
sie da sind
frau ministerin wir haben es gerade
gesehen die deutschen krankenhäuser sind
technisch gut ausgestattet gespart wurde
aber in den letzten jahren am
medizinischen personal ab wann kann das
ein problem werden also zunächst muss
man einmal sagen dass der überwiegende
teil der menschen die haben corona virus
erkrankten milde krankheitssymptome
aufzeigen die zu hause ambulant
behandelt werden können vier prozent der
erkrankten zeigen einen schweren
krankheitsverlauf und für die braucht es
dann die gezeigten intensiv kapazitäten
das ist ganz wichtig deswegen werden
gerade bundesweit auch die intensiv
kapazitäten erhöht beatmungsgeräte
möglichkeiten noch zusätzlich erhöht und
die krankenhäuser sind darauf
eingerichtet
auch ihr personal entsprechend
umzuschichten beispielsweise dadurch
dass operation jetzt nicht nötig sind
verschoben werden um so mit personal
aber auch kapazitäten frei zu bekommen
dh die krankenhäuser sind hier sehr gut
aufgestellt und es ist aber auch
sicherlich sehr hilfreich dass es
endlich die pflegepersonal untergrenzen
gibt damit
eben auch ausreichend personal auf den
stationen in den krankenhäusern
das heißt aber sie machen sich gar keine
sorgen es wird ja schon immer wieder
gesagt dass wir zu wenig personal auch
in normalen zeiten haben und in solchen
zeiten jetzt könnte das doch ein problem
werden ab wann wird es ein problem
also es ist eine herausforderung
zweifelsohne aber dieser herausforderung
wie gesagt stellen sich auch die
krankenhäuser mit ihren entsprechenden
pandemieplänen auch wie sie ihr personal
vor ort einsetzen und die politik hat ja
gerade in der vergangenheit mit der
konzertierten aktion pflege mit der
fachkraft sicherung einiges auch auf den
weg gebracht wie bei uns in rheinland
pfalz schon seit langen jahren um diesen
fachkräftebedarf zu decken
aber wenn jetzt diese intensiv
kapazitäten benötigt werden bin ich
zuversichtlich dass uns dies auch
gemeinsam gelingt so auch zu stellen so
ein bisschen hoffnung höre ich da bei
ihnen auch raus wechseln wir ganz kurz
das thema geschlossene schulen ministern
das hat gedauert
generell eine regelung zu finden oder in
vielen ländern eine regelung zu finden
jetzt gilt es für doch einige
bundesländer auch für rheinland pfalz
für irland warum hat das so lange
gedauert an was lag also es erstmal
zunächst feste stelle was sie in einem
sehr dynamischen prozess befinden das
virus ist neu und die wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse wie gesagt erweitern sich
von tag zu tag beispielsweise hat
gestern noch der führende virologe in
deutschland professor osten gesagt wir
brauchen keine flächendeckenden
schulschließungen weil es nur sinnvoll
ist wenn akutfälle da sind dann
geschlossen sind lage hat sich jetzt
zufolge die lage in der tat die lage hat
sich von gestern morgen auf gestern
abend noch mal deutlich verändert und
wir wollen die zeit nutzen um die
ausbreitung des virus zu verlangsamen
deswegen würden die schulschließung
durchgeführt es geht nicht darum die
kinder vorrangig zu schützen sondern es
geht hier darum wirklich die ausbreitung
des virus zu verlangsamen
das ist das ziel der schulschließung und
der kita schließung wir wollen in dieser
sendung möglichst viele fragen
beantworten die wir heute in ganz
deutschland eingesammelt haben auch für
sie haben wir eine zuschauerfrage schon
zumal ja ich habe mich gefragt ob die
föderalistischen strukturen die wir
haben
oder beispielsweise in rheinland pfalz
sind ja auch die gesundheitsämter kommen
analysiert ob das jetzt gerade eine
glückliche entscheidung ist und ob es
nicht sinnvoller wäre wenn in solchen
zeiten wie jetzt mit der pandemie die
bundesregierung nicht stärkere
einflussmöglichkeiten hätte ihre antwort
also der föderalismus hat wirklich
gerade auch hier in der situation gute
seiten weil es gelingt uns so als länder
gerade auf die kommunalisiert
gesundheitsämter viel regionaler
einzugehen wir als land gewähren
beispielsweise eine 24 stunden
erreichbarkeit für unsere 24
gesundheitsämter
aber natürlich ist es auch ganz wichtig
dass wir uns mit der bundesregierung mit
dem robert koch institut mit den anderen
ländern in der abstimmung befinden
dies wurde jetzt auch noch einmal
intensiviert es sind tägliche
abstimmungsgespräche mit dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium statt das
heißt diese koordination ist natürlich
dann in einem föderalen system auch sehr
wichtig das thema heute
schulschließungen betrifft ja wirklich
sehr sehr viele menschen das aber eine
nachfrage noch dazu viele eltern haben
jetzt ein problem massives problem
sie wissen nicht wie sie ihre kinder
betreuen können wie und kann die politik
da unterstützen wir helfen sie uns
eltern ja also zunächst wird es darum
gehen dass die eltern erstmal versuchen
den eigenen verantwortung natürlich
betreuungsmöglichkeiten zu finden das
sollten nicht oma und opa sein weil es
geht ja eben gerade darum diese
besonders schützen werden
personengruppen die ältere menschen zu
schützen dass sie sich infizieren
aber es geht darum betreuungs option zu
finden ob mit eltern aus der klasse oder
aus der kindergartengruppe man sich
organisiert mit nachbarn mit verwandten
das sind möglichkeiten sollte dies nicht
der fall sein werden notbetreuung
angeboten auch bei uns hier in rheinland
pfalz flächen dick flächendeckend
notbetreuung werden zur verfügung
gestellt damit in dem fall dass eine
betreuung zu hause nicht gewährleistet
werden kann dies dann auch für die
kinder und die familien sichergestellt
ist frau ministerin vielen dank für
ihren besuch und für diese informationen
danke danke schön
das ist zurzeit nur ein gesprächsthema
gibt den familien am arbeitsplatz in
vereinen ist total klar
mittlerweile gibt es weniger
lebensbereiche die von dieser krise
unberührt bleiben unsicherheit und
sorgen treffen die wirtschaft all unsere
arbeitgeber die kleinen betriebe genauso
wie die großen konzerne
aber natürlich ist auch jede familie
betroffen weil sich unser alltag
verändert auf einen schlag andreas weise
christiane seger und stefan schlosser
über deutschland im stresstest einkaufen
an der frischen luft es ist viel los auf
dem wochenmarkt in hannover
die kunden kaufen mehr als sonst im
gegensatz zum supermarkt haben wir sind
unter freiem himmel den vorteil haben
wir haben den druck von klimaanlagen die
irgendwas verteilen können trotzdem die
händler sollen abstand halten nicht wie
sonst lange mit den kunden kleine
desinfektionsmittel
wir waren uns aber die hände und haben
das auch getan drinnen dagegen kaum
jemand die markthalle hannovers
schlämmer tempel in zeiten von corona
üben sogar die gummis verzicht wo früher
kein platz zu bekommen war stehen jetzt
viele tische leer
zwischen 30 und 40 prozent weniger
taktisch frischfisch auch wir bringen
jetzt auch ein neues problem
unsere lieferanten sagen decken die sich
einst mit zulieferer fehlen an jeder
zehnte einzelhändler tut sich bereits
schwer nachschub zu beschaffen
das größte problem in der innenstadt
aber die fehlende kundschaft nur noch
halb so viel wie sonst der umsatz
eingebrochen
tatsächlich wird das bei dem einen oder
anderen insbesondere mittelständisch
geprägten unternehmen auch dazu führen
dass liquiditätsengpässe auftaucht und
dass man lösungen mit den arbeitnehmern
finden muss in richtung kurzarbeit
der einzelhandel kann schon jetzt am
corona virus die ladenbesitzer bangen um
ihre existenz die beschäftigten um ihren
arbeitsplatz
freiburg im breisgau 40.000 pendeln
normalerweise jeden tag aus dem elsass
auf der anderen rheinseite in die
universitätsstadt
seit die französische region zum
risikogebiet erklärt wurde sei es auch
hier viel ruhiger geworden so die
einheimischen die angst dass freiburg
bald auch so eingestuft werden könnte
geht um und spätfolgen für die
stadtkasse sind unausweichlich
alles wird storniert große kongresse
internationale zusammentreffen meetings
fortbildungsveranstaltungen werden
gekürzt oder werden mindestens storniert
das spürt die wirtschaft nicht sage mal
voraus wir werden das auch sprechens im
herbst spüren mit steuereinnahme
ausfällen in den bereich der
gewerbesteuer übernachtungssteuer die
wir in freiburg haben kontrollen auf der
rheinbrücke in kehl
es wird jetzt vor allem nach menschen
mit corona symptomen geschaut sind die
festgestellt wird das gesundheitsamt
alarmiert dass viele der französischen
pendler zu hause bleiben müssen das
spürt auch die firma r m a ein drittel
der belegschaft des herstellers von
pipeline teilen kommt aus dem elsass
das problem ist wir wissen nicht wo es
hingeht und diese unsicherheit bereitet
uns natürlich auch das unternehmen
probleme weil ich weiß ja nicht wie kann
ich reagieren was ich kann nicht nächste
woche noch produzieren wenn ich jetzt
neue angebote machen muss was kann ich
alle bienen habe ich überhaupt noch nie
da beide zur verfügung die aufträge
auszuführen
diese unsicherheit die ist natürlich
schwierig für uns als unternehmen
sie müssen auf sicht fahren anders geht
es nicht in zeiten von corona wie es
sich anfühlt in häuslicher quarantäne zu
sein
darüber reden wir mit birgit aus mainz
per videotelefonie mittwoch wurde sie
positiv auf das corona virus getestet
und so weiter zu machen was da ist aber
schlicht dann informiert familien und
freundeskreis und es sind sehr viele
sehr hilfsbereit und einige bereit uns
einfach zu tätigen qualität zu stellen
auch ihr mann muss zu hause bleiben
obwohl sein virus test negativ war doch
zu dürfen sie sich nicht kommen das
glück haben dass unsere kinder beide
groß und außen hinter dir also ein
zweites schlafzimmer haben weil mir das
glück haben getrennte gästetoilette und
im bad noch mal eine toilette das heißt
da können wir auch wunderbares aus dem
weg gehen also jeder hat seinen bereich
mein mann hat das kleinere klo bekommt
durch das größere ja ansonsten im
wohnzimmer ist es schwer aber man
bekommt natürlich auch gesagt dass man
diese anderthalb bis zwei meter abstand
halten soll
man spricht nicht face to face in der
wehr entfernen und man hat natürlich
lockt ein körperlichen kontakt wie das
tatsächlich nach weiteren mehreren tagen
ja ich sag mal mit den
zwischenmenschlichen funktioniert das
noch nicht sagen weil wir ja eigentlich
uns keine 24 stunden am tag sehen weil
wir beide sticks sind
das sind stand überwachung ob sie die
quarantäne auch einhält gibt es nicht
sagt uns birgt corona virus getestet und
gesundheitsamt telefoniere täglich mit
mir ich werde meinen gesundheitsstand
gefragt da ist also eine große betreuung
es ist aber keine überwachung also man
muss sich nicht vorstellen dass
urplötzlich jemand vor der tür steht und
klingelt sondern es ist an vertrauen
ja ich denk mal an den vernünftigen
deutschen bürger beim deutschen roten
kreuz in rostock 30 prozent weniger
blutspenden in anderen städten sind es
sogar bis zu 50 prozent
ob es nur am corona virus oder auch in
anderen faktoren liegt da sind sie sich
hier nicht sicher doch es sind spezielle
zeiten wir haben einerseits jetzt die
ungewöhnliche lage dass wir einerseits
auf die blutspender gucken müssen die ja
erkranken können und ausbleiben können
aber bei der krone corona
viruserkrankung haben wir ja die
situation dass auch die mitarbeiter
gesund sein müssen dringend gebrauchte
blutpräparate die nicht lange haltbar
sind könnten bald knapp werden
corona und die folgen auch hier eine
herausforderung
frankfurt flughafen beim
speditionsunternehmen hst merken sie die
virus krise ganz direkt denn drei
viertel des geschäfts werden per
luftfracht abgewickelt
die auswirkung für uns sind das die
transportkosten vier bis fünffache
gestiegen sind und dass das
frachtaufkommen kann man sagen ungefähr
90 prozent weniger ist als vor der krise
nur noch zehn prozent momentan
abgewickelt werden
flughafenbetreiber fraport hat er heute
eigentlich positive zahlen zu verkünden
die bilanz 2009 10 sehr gut im moment
aber nur eine randnotiz gegenwart und
nahe zukunft sieht für die branche nicht
gut aus wir haben aktuell in diesen
tagen ein passagier rückgang in der
größenordnung von 45 prozent
der wird jetzt noch größer werden durch
die einreise restriktionen usa und
andere länder
das heißt ich erwarte dass er in den
nächsten wochen auf minus 50 bis minus
60 prozent hoch geht uns fehlen also im
moment jeden tag 80 tausend passagiere
das wird er in die größenordnung 100.000
passagiere jetzt in den nächsten tagen
und wochen gehe fraport beantragt
kurzarbeit sieht sich aber insgesamt gut
gerüstet für diese krise die größte
airline am frankfurter flughafen die
lufthansa überlegt nun staatshilfen zu
beantragen
massive auswirkungen für die wirtschaft
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit clemens
fuß präsident des ifo-instituts guten
abend schön abend die lufthansa braucht
möglicherweise staatshilfe das klingt
wie in der zeit der bankenkrise kann die
deutsche wirtschaft ohne staatshilfe
nicht überleben ja im normalzustand
schon aber das ist jetzt eine krise wie
wir sie wirklich alle 20 jahre mal haben
oder eine solche pandemien wie noch nie
und dann muss man sich eben überlegen
will man es zulassen dass eine firma wie
lufthansa in die insolvenz rutscht dann
kriegen die gläubiger geld nicht wieder
und das transportwesen in europa ist
längere zeit gestört
hier ist es schon sinnvoll wenn der
staat hilft es geht ja weniger darum der
firma wirklich geld zu schenken sondern
kredite bereitzustellen und auch die
banken zu ermutigen weiterhin kredite zu
geben nicht dass da panik entsteht und
schon deshalb die lufthansa in die
insolvenz rutschte sind unternehmen mit
einem funktionierenden geschäftsmodell
das jetzt eine nicht selbst verschuldete
krise absolvieren muss und da ist es zu
vertreten dass der staat hilft im
normalfall muss die wirtschaft natürlich
selbst zurechtkommen hilfe werden
möglicherweise noch mehr firmen brauchen
alles was notwendig ist will die politik
jetzt unternehmen um die wirtschaft zu
stützen hilfskredite ohne begrenzung
sind zugesagt und auch die eu hat
weitreichende hilfen angekündigt wie
wichtig ist all das jetzt in dieser
situation ja das ist schon sehr wichtig
das ist ja eine ungewöhnliche krimis es
geht ja nicht darum jetzt die nachfrage
anzukurbeln wie in anderen krisen dass
die leute wieder reisen sondern wir
müssen ja ein teil der wirtschaft
gewissermaßen einfrieren da wo menschen
zusammenkommen und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir werden die krise
überwunden ist wenn die epidemie
überwunden ist dann der dauerhaften
schaden nicht so groß ist und dafür wird
jetzt das richtige getan
liquiditätshilfen also den unternehmen
bei diesen umsatzeinbrüchen einfach über
die phase hinweg helfen damit sie
endlich in die pleite rutschen mehr kann
man im moment nicht machen
ein land einfach anhalten wie zum
beispiel in italien gibt es irgendeine
vorstellung wie lange man das machen
kann
ja die gibt es nicht weil wir diese art
von epidemie in den letzten jahrzehnten
gar nicht hatten 2003 gab es die
sars-epidemie dies aber im wesentlichen
in china geblieben das virus war nicht
so anstecken man muss ehrlich sagen wir
wissen das nicht
es geht vermutlich einige monate aber
irgendwann wird es natürlich sehr eng
und irgendwann wird der wirtschaftliche
schaden astronomische wenn bei uns china
anschauen da läuft ja einiges wieder an
wenn es wirklich stimmt dass dort die
epidemie zurückgeht dann reden weil eben
über ein paar wochen zum glück nicht
über mehrere monate und das sollte zu
schaffen sein
herr frust über die hilfen für
unternehmen haben wir schon gesprochen
wir reden gleich nochmal weiter vorher
wollen wir aber mal schauen wie sich die
unternehmen selber helfen können welche
möglichkeiten unternehmen haben ganz
praktisch in dieser zeit weiter zu
arbeiten
die größer je nach größe und nach
branche gehen unternehmen natürlich ganz
unterschiedlich mit dieser situation um
es gibt unternehmen die zum beispiel
schon vor vielen tagen ihre
arbeitsweisen komplett umgestellt haben
flexible arbeitsform könnte eine lösung
wäre zumindest ein vorteil sein home
office im großen stil in der hoffnung
auch dann weiterarbeiten zu können wenn
das virus im eigenen unternehmen
ausbricht
ein beispiel aus tettnang von allersberg
normalerweise ist hier jeder
arbeitsplatz besetzt mit menschen die
anti virus programme entwickeln gegen
computerviren
jetzt sorgt virus kidd 19 dafür dass die
gesamte zentrale wie leergefegt ist die
software firma avira in tettnang am
bodensee hat alle 300 mitarbeiter nach
hause geschickt nur noch der
geschäftsführer ist da und lässt uns
rein
wir haben angefangen ist ein paar
schulen geschossen haben und dann haben
wir überlegt was bedeutet das für ein
triple weitere schule schließen werden
gar einfach die entscheidung getroffen
wir sagen unseren beitrag leisten und
vor der verbreitung diese wäre ist
einfach alle nach hause schicken so dass
wir nicht an der verbreitung sky werden
könnten radikale vorsichtsmaßnahme
bisher kein corona infizierter
mitarbeiter oder ein verdachtsfall bei
avira einer digitalen firma wo fast alle
ausschließlich am computer arbeiten
deshalb geht das mit dem home office
sofern die internetverbindung
funktioniert
sechs kilometer vom unternehmen entfernt
sieht das dann so aus bei andreas
unfried und lina komarek seit zwei tagen
zu hause
am anfang war es schon sehr komisch weil
klar jeder von avira hat sein monitor
geschnappt hat seinen laptop geschnappt
und ist dann mit dem wägelchen praxis
nach draußen gefahren und jeder hat so
das büro verlassen und zwar auch
irgendwie ein bisschen traurig weil wir
haben sehr guten team spirit stadt team
sitzt jetzt der freund gegenüber und
koordiniert seine fünf teams per
video-konferenz könnt ihr mich auch es
ist ein bisschen eng provisorisch und
keine dauerlösung
gerade auch mit den verschiedenen
arbeitsbereichen die wir haben mit auch
vertraulichen dingen die ich nicht weiß
wissen darf aus ihrem bereich oder sie
nicht aus meinem bereich ist es eine
herausforderung absolut die beiden
versuchen trotzdem so normal wie möglich
weiter zu arbeiten wie sie werden wohl
immer mehr menschen in den nächsten
tagen von zu hause aus arbeiten müssen
die gewerkschaften begrüßen das
natürlich kann beim mobilen arbeiten in
den grenzen der arbeit entstehen und das
nicht auszuschließen dieser tage aber
ich glaube wir haben eine besondere
situation und deswegen sagen wir da was
geht machen muss und hier geht es nicht
um würdig die grundsatzfrage zu klären
wir regeln das rechtlichen langen seilen
ohnehin müssen menschen vor infektionen
geschützt werden und deswegen muss man
pragmatisch reagieren bei avira in
tettnang wird es nicht nur in der
kantine erst mal bis nach ostern weiter
so aussehen menschenleer und die
geschäftsführung hofft einfach dass die
mitarbeiter zu hause motiviert bleiben
trotz ausnahme situation herr professor
fuß dieses beispiel lässt sich natürlich
nicht auf alle branchen und berufe
anwenden aber wie flexibel sind deutsche
unternehmen generell aufgestellt ja die
flexibilität nimmt schon sehr zu gerade
home office war auch vor der krise ein
thema in allen unternehmen zunehmend
viele menschen möchten die möglichkeit
haben ab und zu mal von zu hause aus zu
arbeiten
es gibt verschiedene formen das
einzurichten man muss in diesen bereich
investieren
aber die die digitalisierung ermöglicht
uns das jetzt sehen wir wie wichtig das
ist dass wir uns mit diesen techniken
auseinandersetzen ist viel ist dass ich
bin überzeugt dass es sind so gut wie
allen firmen schon ein thema ist das so
vielleicht einen nebeneffekt dass sich
durch diese krise auch solche punkte
beschleunigen werden dass innovationen
schneller umgesetzt werden ganz bestimmt
kann ich mir vorstellen auch wenn wir an
die vielen geschäftsreisen denken die
wir machen man wird vielleicht künftig
doch ein bisschen mehr mit
videokonferenztechnik machen dass man
muss eben ab und zu so einen kleinen
anstoß kriegen das wirklich einzusetzen
sich daran zu gewöhnen und dann sieht
man das klappt ganz gut
clemens fuest vielen dank für diese
einschätzungen informationen schöne
grüße nach münchen
herzlichen dank nochmals
all die maßnahmen die uns im alltag
jetzt erschweren die unsere
freizeitgestaltung einschränken der
dringende appell das soziale miteinander
zu minimieren
all das hat nur einen grund wir müssen
es dem virus so schwer wie möglich
machen
noch haben wir keine andere chance einen
impfstoff gibt es nicht noch nicht
zum stand der forschung und über die
große hoffnung auf erfolg berichtet
sandra so sein kann
es ist ein wettlauf gegen die zeit hier
im labor der biotech-firma cure weg wird
geforscht an einem impfstoff gegen das
corona virus es ist nicht das einzige
unternehmen weltweit suchen experten
nach einem impfstoff etwas was die
pandemie aufhalten kann
der ansatz der tübinger wissenschaftler
ist relativ neu für ihre forschung
brauchen sie das virus selbst nicht in
ihren laboren nur seinen bauplan
die forscher sind optimistisch eine
waffe gegen das neuartige corona beer
ausbauen zu können
jetzt sind wir gerade ein notfall
entwicklungen das heißt es schnell wie
es geht an den menschen zu kommen und da
den impfstoff zu testen
danach hoffen wir dass wir in eine
normale entwicklung kommen das heißt das
kann sich dann auch über mehrere jahre
hinziehen ist auch wichtig weil ich
glaube schon dass dieses corona virus
sich festsetzen kann so ähnlich wie die
grippe und dann jedes jahr wieder
zurückkommt das war neben den grippe
impfstoff auch ein crooner impfstoff
dann zur verfügung haben auch andere
sind dem virus auf der spur
die professorin marilyn addo vom
deutschen zentrum für
infektionsforschung in hamburg sie hat
unter anderem eine impfstudie gegen
ebola geleitet corona ist die neue
herausforderung
die virus sequenz die man braucht um
einen impfstoff herzustellen konnte
schnell entschlüsselt werden nun folgen
weitere phasen
die impfstoffentwicklung ist wird die
auf hochtouren schon angelaufen und das
ist so schnell gegangen wie es noch
bisher noch nie gewesen ist und
tatsächlich sind auch schon die ersten
studien einen menschen haben letzte
woche angefangen das hat es noch nie
gegeben also wir kennen das virus
eigentlich erst seit dezember und sind
jetzt schon im märz dabei neue
impfstoffe zu testen
dennoch braucht diese entwicklung
relativ lange und wir werden diesen
impfstoff welche auch immer sein wird
nicht vor nächstem jahr verfügbar haben
große hoffnung setzt man deshalb auf
antivirale medikamente die bei bereits
infizierten zur behandlung eingesetzt
werden und verhindern sollen dass die
atemwegsinfektion lebensgefährlich wird
forscher prüfen zurzeit eine reihe
vorhandener medikamente wie hier am
deutschen primatenzentrum in göttingen
das medikament wird bereits in japan
eingesetzt aber nicht zur behandlung der
korona virusinfektionen sondern einer
damit nicht verwandten erkrankung wir
wissen nun dass dieses medikament auch
gegen das neue virus wirkt und würden
gerne wissen zumindest in zellkulturen
würden gerne wissen ob es auch in der
klinik eingesetzt werden kann zur
behandlung von kubik 19
die zeit drängt wissenschaftler aus der
ganzen welt haben sich deshalb vernetzt
um den tödlichen virus den kampf
anzusagen
ein experte der uns helfen wird die
vielen fragen zu beantworten professor
stephan becker virologe von der uni
marburg herzlich willkommen hallo herr
professor sie selbst und ihr team
forschen auch gerade an einem impfstoff
gegen krohne sagen sie uns wie weit sind
sie denn wir machen das zusammen mit
vielen anderen gruppen und dann damit
der fado die wir gerade eben gesehen
haben und weiteren gruppen noch und der
impfstoff den wir quasi uns vorgenommen
haben zu machen der ist jetzt quasi fast
fertig aber damit ist der weg noch lange
nicht zu ende
und was kommt dann ja dann muss man ihn
testen da muss man natürlich raus gegen
wirkt er denn eigentlich ja also dann
macht zuerst diesen impfstoff mittels
molekularbiologischer methoden und dann
guckt man wirkt dieser impfstoff
eigentlich und wir haben einen impfstoff
rausgesucht der sehr ähnlich ist wie an
dem stoff den wir gerade getestet haben
gegen ein anderes corona virus dieses
märz corona virus und wir hoffen dass
wir jetzt viele
die erfahrungen die wir mit dem mars
gruner virus gemacht haben für das saas
corona virus nutzen können und deswegen
auch die zeit dann bis zum einsatz
dieses virus in klinischen studien
relativ kurz sein wird
wann rechnen sie damit wir hoffen dass
wir ende des jahres in die klinischen
studien gehen können
jetzt gibt es ein medikament das
normalerweise gegen ebola eingesetzt
wird auch helfen soll wenn man eben
erkrankt ist
was können sie uns darüber sagen das ist
natürlich eine sehr gute möglichkeit und
eine große hoffnung im moment das man
also medikamente die schon im einsatz
sind gegen eine andere erkrankung dass
man die dann auch jetzt nutzen kann
gegen das neue corona virus und das wird
im moment gerade versucht das wird
untersucht auch in klinischen studien
die sind angelaufen in den usa bereits
und es wird jetzt in den nächsten wochen
und monaten hier in deutschland
ebenfalls mit diesem medikament getestet
werden und das würde dann natürlich
bedeuten dass man sehr schnell ein
medikament zur hand hat das gegen das
neue corona virus einsatz beißt herr
professor wir haben uns heute den ganzen
tag in deutschland um gehört viele
fragen eingesammelt drei fragen für sie
was mich persönlich bewegt oder
interessiert ist wie ich mich am besten
vor dem corona virus schützen denn jetzt
auch mit meinem persönlichen umfeld
meine freundin ist jetzt auch schwanger
da bewegt uns das natürlich auch extrem
also wir beide haben sie ist
krankenschwester sie weiß wie es wie man
mit solchen erkrankungen umgeht auf der
anderen seite fragen wir uns natürlich
doch wie gehen wir am besten damit um
wenn man nach draußen gehen
wie verhalten wir uns einfach am besten
das würde uns denkt schon mal am meisten
interessieren
woran kann man das erkennen husten die
menschen auf eine bestimmte art und
weise hört sich der husten der trockene
an was ist mit denen die krank geworden
sind und die dann angeblich immun sind
kann man sich vielleicht doch noch mal
neu anstecken oder wenn sich der virus
verändert gibt es dann wieder eine
neuerkrankung jetzt viele fragen von
wenn man mit der letzten an
da ist man immun wenn man schon mal
erkranktes gibt es da erfahrungen
wir nehmen das an allerdings dass bei
corona während sodass man dass diese
immunität nicht lange anhält
also die geht wieder weg nach einigen
wochen oder monaten und dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit oder die möglichkeit
dass man sich wieder an steckt da aber
wir gehen alle davon aus dass nach der
infektion man sich zunächst mal nicht
mehr an steckt die unsicherheit bei
vielen ist ja das haben wir auch gehört
wenn man selber hustet wenn man selber
so ein gefühl hat ist jedoch so viel
darüber gesprochen dass man schon so ein
bisschen in sich rein gehört ganz anders
als vorher
woran erkennt man es denn wirklich man
kann das also rein von den symptomen
herrn nicht wirklich gut unterscheiden
von einer grippe erkrankung oder von
vielen anderen atemwegserkrankungen auch
das lässt sich nur labor mit mittels
einen mittels labortechnik unterscheiden
anders geht das nicht
wir haben eine frage gehabt wie schütze
ich mich da gibt es natürlich ganz viele
hinweise hängt bei der fängt bei der
hygiene an und eben bei dem minimieren
der sozialen kontakte wenn jetzt die
freundin schwanger ist muss der
zuschauer sich besondere sorgen machen
ja das ist natürlich eine besonders
schwierige situation weil wir von
anderen viruserkrankungen wissen dass
schwangere da besonders gefährdet sind
und schwerere verläufe haben von dieser
erkrankung das scheint bei diesem neuen
kroner virus nicht so zu sein also dass
schwangere müssen nicht fürchten dass
sie schwerer krank werden als nicht
schwangere frauen und natürlich wir
haben das jetzt den letzten wochen
ständig gehört was machen wir um uns
nicht anzustecken ja wir gehen ein stück
zurück wir geben uns nicht mehr die
hände
wir haben nicht mehr so viel kontakt mit
anderen menschen und das sind die sachen
die wir für uns selbst tun können wir
versuchen dann natürlich auch die andere
nicht anzustecken falls wir selbst krank
sind wir wussten die allen den
ellenbeuge und so weiter
das und dann noch wichtig natürlich nie
zu vergessen händewaschen ganz wichtig
eine zuschauerfrage haben auch für sie
schauen sie mal ich hätte die frage zum
corona virus wie sieht es damit aus in
der infrarotkabine wie sieht so eine
trockensauna aus wie sie zum dampfbad
aus ist es da ansteckender als sonst
oder nicht ganz so ansteckend ja was
meinen die experten
dankeschön was meinte experten als
meinte experte der experte meint dass
coronaviren sehr sensitiv sind auf hitze
ja und wenn sie in der sauna sind und da
ist sind die oberflächen alle 80 bis 100
grad da hält sich das gruner virus nicht
lange
also das ist schon mal safe wieder
seiner infrarotkamera ist das kann ich
nicht sagen das weiß ich nicht
und die letzte frage waren auch ist das
was im wasser im schwimmbad das
schwimmbadwasser ist gechlort insofern
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass das
kroner virus lange infektions bleibt
relativ gering trotzdem die sozialen
kontakte minimieren
also vielleicht kann man auch auf diese
aktivitäten ein bisschen verzichten in
nächster zeit professor becker vielen
dank bisher sie bleiben noch ein
bisschen bei uns bis zum ende der
sendung soziale kontakte minimieren das
ist die stoßrichtung darum muss es in
den nächsten tagen gehen und darum das
weiß ich ganz genau ist die technik
hängen geblieben
darum muss es in den nächsten tagen
geben
der übliche berufsverkehr hammer an
knotenpunkten wie dem berliner
alexanderplatz wie immer dichtes
gedränge volle züge in normalen zeiten
nichts was fahrgäste beunruhigen würde
doch was ist schon normal dieser tage
ausmaße annimmt guckt man hat man nicht
doch jetzt ein bisschen mehr darauf
verzichten kann und nur noch das
nötigste tat handschuhe an druck auf den
knopf
also ich finds für mich okay ein
mulmiges gefühl schon weil manche noch
genießen und nicht irgendwo in die
armbeuge oder so geblieben gesamte übrig
ansonsten muss ich zu hause bleiben
arbeitsschluss arbeiten gehen die
berliner verkehrsbetriebe haben schon
vor tagen reagiert ihren anderen städten
auch darf in bussen nicht mehr vorn
eingestiegen werden die fahrer sollen
besser geschützt werden
in den u-bahnen wird appelliert sich an
die üblichen hygieneregeln zu halten
jetzt soll das öffentliche leben noch
weiter eingeschränkt werden für die bvg
keine große herausforderung denn nach
und nach die schulen in berlin schließen
dann fallen natürlich auch die schüler
verkehre weg das heißt dann haben wir zu
einer bestimmten uhrzeit eindeutig
weniger fahrgäste dann braucht man
natürlich auch weniger fahrzeuge und
auch weniger personal
darauf kann man aber reagieren darauf
reagieren wir jede
ferien sind mit einem fahrplan anders
die situation im fernverkehr spürbar
weniger reisende seit anfang märz heißt
es von seiten der bahn
jetzt werden die kulanzregelungen für
bereits gekaufte tickets nochmals
verbessert wir beide haben gestern
miteinander abgestimmt dass wir allen
kunden die eine reise im moment bis ende
april geplant haben die möglichkeit
geben sparpreise sparpreis tickets
umzutauschen in gutscheine fernbus
anbieter beklagen wie die bahn auch
weniger reisende marktführer vlexplus
kündigt bereits an das streckennetz
anzupassen im fernverkehr hinterlässt
das corona virus schon jetzt spuren ja
bei mir sind jetzt nochmal professor
becker und sarah tacke zusammen schön
dass sie und schön dass du noch mal
hergekommen bist der professor noch mal
an sie die frage bus und bahn fahren das
macht natürlich nicht nur die menschen
in berlin das machen sehr viele
wer kann soll darauf verzichten ist das
ihr rad ja das geht ja in die gleiche
richtung wie wir das jetzt die ganze
zeit gehört haben also der der sozialen
kontakt minimieren ist natürlich
besonders wichtig bei leuten die man
nicht kennt wo man nicht weiß wo wie die
sich verhalten haben der letzten zeit ob
die kontakt hatten mit erkrankten und
insofern denke ich wenn es geht sollte
man darauf verzichten ja und ich nochmal
die frage werden vor das thema
quarantäne in dem einen beitrag
da gibt es ja ganz fest gesetze
regelungen was darf ich und was nicht
danach kommt darauf an was für eine
quarantäne ist wenn seine selbst
verordnete ist viele ging jetzt
freiwillig in häusliche quarantäne ohne
dass das angeordnet wurde dann darf ich
alles wenn es aber eine behördlich
angeordnete car athen ist dann muss ich
das wirklich ernst nehmen darf ich
eigentlich noch nicht mal mehr den müll
vor die tür bringen und wenn ich in
quarantäne im krankenhaus bin und immer
wieder ausbrechen wollen würde dann kann
man mich auch in abgeschlossenen teil
des krankenhauses bringen und wenn man
gegen kantine regeln wirklich verstößt
dann kann das bis zu zwei jahre
freiheitsstrafe oder geldstrafe bedeuten
aber man sollte es nicht nur deshalb
nicht machen sondern natürlich auch im
sinne
der gesundheits von einen anderen wenn
man jetzt nicht in quarantäne ist
professor
das ist so schwer wahrscheinlich den
richtigen ratschlag zu geben aber sich
jetzt wirklich selber freiwillig so
einzuigeln und wirklich gar nichts mehr
zu machen
das wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht ihr
rad sein oder
das ist nicht mein rat also es geht ja
es geht darum die risiken zu minimieren
die man hat ja und möglichst wir haben
das jetzt ja schon häufiger angesprochen
also es geht darum mit weniger menschen
kontakt zu haben und die entfernung zu
den anderen menschen bis hin zu erhöhen
sodass die dass die chance dass man sich
ansteckt bei jemand anderem eben
geringer wird aber ich glaube es kann
nicht darum gehen alles einzustellen
eine zuschauerfrage hätten wir noch für
sie also meine frage wäre inwiefern das
also was ich dagegen tun könnte um eben
nicht meine großeltern beispielsweise zu
gefährden oder ab wann der punkt
erreicht an dem ich vielleicht sogar den
kontakt eben unterbinden müsste um halt
eben eine gefährdung meiner großeltern
oder beispielsweise auch anderen älteren
verwandten eben zu umgehen um das zu
umgehen das ist ja auch eine frage die
mit dem heutigen tag wirklich viele
beschäftigt weil viele großeltern auf
kinder aufpassen
also auch die enkelkinder die jetzt
nicht mehr die schule gehen können
gibt es da einen ratschlag sondern jetzt
wirklich gar nicht mehr besuchen
ja das sind diese diese schwierigen
fragen im moment und die sind deswegen
schwierig weil gegen ältere menschen
oftmals eine schwerere erkrankung
erleiden als junger menschen und
deswegen denke ich wenn man selbst krank
ist egal ob das corona virus oder
influenza oder sonst was ist dann sollte
man mit den großeltern keinen kontakt
haben und wenn man kontakt hatte mit
jemand der erkrankte ist sollte man das
ebenfalls vermeiden wenn das soweit ist
nicht der fall ist dann denke ich kann
man die großeltern sehen aber man sollte
es vermeiden sich zu umarmen zu küssen
sondern man sollte einfach diesen
abstand wahren dem von dem er gerade
eben auch gesprochen haben also zwei
meter ist glaube ich eine ganz gute
entfernung
die letzte frage an dich nochmal zum
thema quarantäne zurück wenn man eben
gezwungen ist keine kontakte mehr
wahrnehmen zu dürfen
man sitzt dann da in der wohnung im haus
hat man da eigentlich irgendeinen
anspruch darauf dass einem jemand hilft
oder muss man sich aus der situation
wirklich komplett selber versorgen
erstmal klar selber helfen aber im
zweifel kann man sich dann also wenn man
wirklich in quarantäne sein muss und
dass nicht nur die freiwillige aus angst
und voller gekannt ihn ist dann kann man
sich auch im krankenhaus begeben und
wird dort versorgt weil man unter
quarantäne sein muss und da wird man
dann auch versorgt
sonst heißt wahrscheinlich viele
kontakte nutzen die anderen helfen die
haben was vor die türe stellen und ich
glaube da ist die hilfsbereitschaft ja
auch sicherlich enorm
ich danke ihnen beiden ich danke dir
sehr für die hilfe ich habe viel gelernt
und viel neues erfahren vielen dank so
gerne alles was nötig ist das
gesundheitssystem und die wirtschaft
werden gestützt so das versprechen alles
was nötig ist gilt auch für uns alle die
wir uns das leben so schwer wie möglich
machen darum geht's wenn unsere
informationen und antworten dabei helfen
würde mich das freuen
noch mehr infos und alle weiteren
entwicklungen gibt es für sie auf der
heute de und in der zdf mediathek
das war unser zdf spezial hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit der krimiserie der
staatsanwalt hochzeit in rot ich danke
ihnen für ihr interesse und wünschen
noch einen schönen abend